hey you guys I'm right right I'm Jerry
we're gonna watch this trailer for a
movie about Horrible Bosses called
Horrible Bosses part two so starring the
cast of Horrible Bosses directed by the
director of Horrible Bosses that's a
whole lot of Horrible Bosses that's a
whole lot of Horrible Bosses I wonder if
they have the same bosses or different
bosses I'm hoping this is the exact same
plot
I think Horrible Bosses - from what I've
been hearing people haven't seen it's
not going in the exact same direction so
this just gonna be there's gonna be a
good thing Jerry I hope so I mean
there's good things what they should hey
I'm trying to tell you something
this could be a good things or make it
out I'm not just Kevin Spacey
give us the $500,000
with a grown man
no dude it's a whole thing Rex I know
this is way better
they're stopped
Oh catch it though it's funny no I
always like a good time actually yeah
like I'm always worried whenever they
make sequels to movies like this but
that that looks pretty fun no I mean it
is they gave new direction it's like
they managed to get everybody back but
also bring in some new exciting people
yeah Oh Chris planet Christoph Waltz all
right like yeah man they got Jennifer
Aniston back who's sexy yep oh that's
the second she appeared on screen I'm
like I wonder and it probably will like
this movie is probably gonna have a seat
where it's like stop the movie Jennifer
Aniston still got it though right like
every movie needs that every movie she's
in happened yeah I think they're
necessary we're constantly being
reminded that she's still got it which
isn't bad but yeah I like the idea of
them like trying to make enough money
where they can just retire that seems
like the next logical step these they're
like the most hard-core energetic lazy
people yeah yeah I don't want to work
let's come up with something really
difficult and risky in order to make
that happen but not like in Charlie Day
like he was owning that trailer man
they're really promoting the hell out of
him in that one yeah like he was getting
all those funny ones yeah well cuz you
know Charlie day went in any sort of
comedic dynamic he's in oh it seems like
he is the wacky guy like the wild-card
guy well there's differences from It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia Charlie Day
but it was essentially the same role
it's different shades but he has the
same status in any grave ironmen cuz you
know he's kind of wiry and squeaky he's
never status one he's never the guy
who's like you know the straight man but
he was my favorite in Horrible Bosses
yeah anyway guys if you're near the
channel you can subscribe for the real
rejects you can it's possible with new
to modern technology and if you like you
can check out Gerry's reasons to Gerry
playlist it's possible you could where
he has
movie reviews in his car and other
things that he does every once in a
while we should do the rest of this
video with our eyes closed just cuz that
would be like really strange Adam
Freeman a it's a giving me shout out to
my youtube can you me shout to my
Instagram it's Doctor Who 12 I post
doctor who picks Doctor Who 1200 we're
doing the closed eyes Doctor Who 12 you
deserve a shout-out because you are
supporting one of the greatest shows I
have never seen before so good for you
man I like Doctor Who
Oh your doctor who's an amazing show
deal yeah
it's good to know I keep feeling like
we're about to kiss I can't tell far
away that's good but Adam Freeman who is
the son of I think I've made this joke
before this sounds familiar
well I don't know anymore Martin Freeman
that's a different Freeman at least yeah
I mean I the habit I have is this
constantly saying Freeman and then going
Morgan Freeman joke of course cuz I know
this guy named Greg Aleph do you do you
know yeah and then everyone's always
like hey you really did Jessica and Greg
hates it he hates it look at me look at
me right now you [ __ ] don't you
ever say that to Greg if you ever happen
to meet him or see him however unless
you're talking about his cousin Jessica
that's this wholly different story
you're on earth in Daniel oh my god
we're going in Seattle yeah that's
awesome
that's where I grew up could please vlog
a little bit while you're out there
shout me out please
Jonathan Daniel I hear Seattle is an
amazing amazing piece of the country in
some ways it rains a lot it's all about
you know to be honest well it rains a
lot of there's like a lot of really you
know important music has come out of
there
like there's a heavy music culture and
Starbucks Starbucks was invented there I
think so Oh Cameron this guy's name
Yolanda Daniel Daniel I'm Brad I see you
get me Jerry we're buds
anyway ulanda Demetri
we're gonna do the third one with our
eyes open because I I can't see if my
camera's gonna cut mister something 65 I
demand a shout out also nice video
mister something 65 feels weird
all right mister something 65 what is 65
that we're talking about here why is it
in 69 but um
that's a Ryan right right that's a Ryan
right it's ryan right cocteau I just
like that this that this started out
being like very demanding and like you
Porter give me a shout out like like
it's saved at them with a nice sentiment
yes honestly it would have hurt if it
was reversed the other way around nice
video give me a [ __ ] shout out hey
mister something you are everything to
these guys
mister something 65 I'll tell you a
mister something alright man I like it
when a girl messing around with calls me
Greg in bed I know not my name but it
turns me off it's weird
it turns me on it's good so they're like
oh Gregory I'm like why do you like to
roleplay and pretend you're Greg Kinnear
yeah that Greg Kinnear is my hero and
then you you roleplay that you're your
you know sexual partners Eva Mendes and
it's like you're in an alternate version
of stuck on you where it's like really
erotic and you're not a conjoined twin
at all that's that's beautiful I should
totally
with my eyes closed I can see it yeah
that is that is beautiful now that's
something